a la guerra nuclear ya le pasará factura
a la economía internacional según la
organización para la cooperación y el
desarrollo económico este año el
producto interno bruto mundial podría
ser un punto porcentual más bajo y aún
peor debido a la guerra la inflación
podría aumentar hasta dos puntos
porcentuales
lewis la guerra está provocando un
fuerte choque de oferta que se suma a
las presiones inflacionistas y a las
perturbaciones por la crisis del cobe 19
está el impacto negativo sobre la
confianza que al mismo tiempo afectará
negativamente en el consumo privado y en
las decisiones de inversión de las
empresas en business investment
aunque rusia y ucrania solo representan
el 2% del producto interno bruto mundial
su impacto en los mercados de la energía
y las materias primas es enorme rusia
suministra el 27 por ciento de las
importaciones de crudo de la unión
europea y más del 41 por ciento del gas
natural al bloque aunque exporta más
productos a américa latina' de los que
importa la mayor parte de las
exportaciones rusas llegan a brasil y
méxico las dos mayores economías de la
región representadas en fertilizantes
acero petróleo refinado y las vacunas
sputnik
en el contexto actual europa en
particular tendrá que estar a la altura
de las circunstancias y reevaluar la
estructura y el diseño del mercado para
garantizar la seguridad y el acceso a la
energía sin dejar de centrarse en lograr
la neutralidad del carbono para 2050 el
organismo internacional mencionó que
eeuu y la zona euro serían los más
afectados y recomendó a los gobiernos
que las medidas que se tomen en los
periodos de crisis deben ser temporales
y específicas de lo contrario podrían
tener efectos aún peores